hi I'm Erik Bosse since riding around
homecoming sequel the upcoming
spider-man far from home
he's coming july 2019 just a few months
after Avengers 4 and as more and more
behind the scenes social media post come
out it's appearing increasingly likely
that far from home could actually
feature the sinister six this is all
thanks to Tom Holland whose generous
insta game has made any trailers for
this movie completely unnecessary who
are all the new characters and possible
villains that have been announced for
this movie
and what could these announcements tell
us about far from home story let's start
way back at the end of spider-man
homecoming in the post-credits scene we
saw Michael Keaton's villain character
Adrian Toomes aka the vulture behind
bars crossing paths with this guy now
this is one of Tim's old associates Mac
Gargan played by Michael mando so I got
that tattoo on his neck the scorpion
shaped one of a scorpion and the marvel
comics Matt gargons alter-ego is the
spider-man villain scorpion and he says
this interesting line of tubes I've got
some boys on the outside who'd love to
meet him you know take a picture slice
his throat put his head in the dryer why
a dryer Mack I guess just don't mix
Peters bloody severed head with the
white clothes nasty stains gargons words
got us all pumped because any hint
toward a group of criminals conspiring
to kill spider-man has to be considered
a nod to the sinister six they're a team
of six spider-man villains led by Doctor
Octopus to kill Spidey
originally it was Doc Ock vulture
electro Kraven the hunter Mysterio and
Sandman though the lineup has changed
over the years with other villains like
Hobgoblin chameleon and Rhino and
scorpion rotating in there have been
loose plans at Sony to make a sinister
six movie four years remember the
amazing spider-man 2 in 2014 ended with
a major tease toward the censors sixteen
headed up by Harry Osborn it would have
included Rhino vulture Doc Ock Mysterio
and Kraven the hunter Drew Goddard was
originally going to direct this sister 6
spin-off actually saying he wanted to
adapt a more classic adaptation that
would have included Sandman in made goth
politer
he actually wanted it to be a Redemption
story without spider-man but then Sony
scrapped these plans when they announced
a rebooted version of spider-man in the
MCU in a joint partnership with Marvel
Studios also there was a leaked email
from Sony executives suggesting plans to
do a sinister six movie as part of this
partners
assuming the deal went well and it
definitely has spider-man homecoming
topped both the amazing spider-man films
and Tom Hollands roles a civil war an
infinity war have made his version of
the character a huge hit and now as we
get updates on spider-man far from home
it definitely does appear to have
multiple villains being added to the
cast first it was announced that Michael
Keaton would be returning as Adrian
Toomes vulture in that post-credit scene
with Mac Gargan tombs defended Peter
Parker by refusing to give up his name
but whether he's a reluctant villain or
caves and helps gargons guys track down
Peter vulture will be part of the sequel
in some way and I think it's safe to
assume scorpion will be as well now
scorpion in the comics is similar to
spider-man and that his DNA is enhanced
with arachnid abilities and he wears a
suit with a cybernetically controlled
tail this version of Mac Gargan appears
to be adapted from the Ultimate Comics
in which Gargan is a Mexican crime boss
now interestingly Mac Gargan later
becomes one of the hosts of the Venom
symbiote so he could be a way to spread
venom into the MCU crossover part of the
Sony verse that is if the studio wants
to leave the Tom Hardy Eddie Brock venom
version in its own sub universe so with
vulture and Scorpion that's two villains
but around the time of Keaton's return
was announced reports came out that Jake
Gyllenhaal was in talks to play Mysterio
Mysterio is Quentin Beck originally a
special effects wizard and stuntman
working in Hollywood he's a master
illusionist who uses technology in
hypnosis and smokescreens to get inside
his victims heads and wears a fishbowl
style helmet to protect himself and
while we've been waiting for more
details about Mysterio and trying to
track down pictures of Jake Gyllenhaal
in London it was announced that Turkish
actor Newman a car would join the far
from home cast as a character known only
as Dimitri now there is a Demetri in the
spider-man comics Dimitri Smerdyakov for
the pronunciation it's also known as the
chameleon now the chameleon is a master
of disguise some versions of the villain
over the years have given him
shape-shifting powers but the original
in the most recent version are more
practical he wears a mask of people's
faces and he impersonates them perfectly
he's basically a Tom Cruise in every
Mission Possible movie in an Instagram
post a car included some hashtags that
seem to confirm Jake Gyllenhaal as
Mysterio in the movie along with
appearances from samuel l.jackson as
Nick Fury and Cobie Smulders as Maria
Hill in the most recent possibilities of
a new villain came one
again from Tom Holland who took to
Instagram to plug a charity he works
with joking about a stand-in who does
his stunts now there's two interesting
details about this footage first notice
that t-shirt rack those set the scene in
Venice Italy establishing the city as
one of Peters many destinations in this
European adventure that will also
feature London and Prague but more
importantly that big wave attack has led
to some speculation that the villain
hydro-man could play into the plot as
well Hydra man is more bench he gains
the ability to manipulate water after
spiderman knocks him from a cargo ship
that was experimenting in ocean water
and yeah practically speaking he's kind
of a water version of sandman and hydra
man did actually join da [ __ ] in a
pseudo sinister six group called the
sinister syndicate in the spiderman ride
at Universal Studios Orlando so that
makes four to five possible villains all
appearing in spider-man far from home so
if this isn't an attempt to assemble a
sinister six in the MCU then what is it
we know the studio has been dying to put
the sinister six in some movie and this
is the first real opportunity for them
to do it Sony recently reminded us all
that they still retain the film rights
to 900 Marvel characters and any chance
they get to make money off of them
they're gonna jump on it ever since Sony
began its deal with Marvel they've had
one movie home coming to establish the
new incarnation of Peter Parker and to
team-up movies in which he plays a
supporting role now spider-man will
finally have a big sequel Otto himself
where he can expand his own world with
several spider-man iconic villains and
at this sinister six theory is true that
just leaves one more mystery villain I'm
gonna go out there and say Doc Ock
mostly because the Sinister Six has
classically been his operation now j.b
smoove has also been announced to play a
major character in far from home maybe
[ __ ] will be the party place the saying
the tinkerer from homecoming is still
out there after that movie and I could
see him tinkering some new scavenged
Atari or Ultron tech into some
cybernetic arms that could be used to
rip off Peters head and throw it in a
dryer while the other three arms add the
dryer sheet and insert the quarters and
twist a knob to permanent press really
the frustrating thing about all this is
it's probably gonna be a while before we
get confirmation on the sinister six
either way because according to the MCU
guys Peter Parker's just a pile of lint
that Tony Stark astha keeps shaking
office clothes I suppose that's what
happens after you don't clean out the
lint trap after you put Peter Parker's
head in the dryer until we get some
announcements about Avengers 4 like a
trailer or a synopsis or a freakin title
at least the studios are obviously gonna
be pretty hamstrung to reveal any
details about far from home because they
would have to explain how spider-man is
even alive before they reveal anything
about the villains so here's a question
I'll leave you with who else should be
another villain in far from home would
you prefer Doc Ock or maybe Green Goblin
or venom or carnage comments down below
with your thoughts and follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at ei vas to keep
track of me and some fun projects like
on the works for you guys like this
video share it around and subscribe to
new rockstars for more of this Marvel
nerd theory stuff because Lin spider-man
far from homes title is revealed to be
just a fake cover for its real title
spider-man and the sinister six while
everyone else is surprised by this news
you're gonna be like boss called it and
if that isn't the case he'll just forget
you ever saw this video
[Music]